house hunters are often enticed to a
property by kitchens and closet space
some fearless home buyers in new orleans
are looking for more
in what's considered more one of the
most haunted cities in the u.s
homes supposedly inhabited by ghosts are
a big draw
jamie wax has that story
it's been said that in new orleans every
house has a story
and with over three centuries of history
perhaps it shouldn't be surprising that
some of the storytellers refuse to let a
little thing like
death silence them but there definitely
is
at times energy that is not ours right
you we
feel a presence you hear sounds you know
you turn
open door doors open tv turns on by
itself
lights turn on by themselves liz and
jason williams purchased a historic home
on legendary saint charles avenue just
over a year ago
behind us in the dining room is the
place where i think we hear the noises
the most the footsteps directly overhead
the personal disclosure is all the more
interesting because jason isn't just a
homeowner but also a fixture of local
politics
jason you are the city council president
new orleans i am okay second term
no in no city in america could i imagine
a politician happily saying yes i live
in a haunted house
well we have a we have a different
relationship with the dead in
in the city of new orleans not only is
it not a liability for a politician to
say he lives in a haunted house in new
orleans
but a ghost could even be a selling
point here according to realtor and
preservationist katie witry
you know new orleans has a storied past
and i feel that people
relate to the narrative and the stories
that the houses have had
we headed to the oldest and most famous
neighborhood in new orleans
the french quarter where there's a ghost
story around
every corner it's a one bedroom one bath
ground floor unit
and i had asked her why she'd actually
put haunted on the sign and she had said
because the owner
actually has felt spirits or ghosts
actually in the space
and here ghostly presences don't just
benefit residential properties but
commercial ones too
like restaurants muriels and tableau the
restaurant's video of possible
paranormal activity went viral
i was in their wine cellar and bottles
just kept coming flying off of the
shelves and so
now all of a sudden people really want
to be there
it strikes me that for a record seventh
time
this year alone as we do this interview
new orleans is in the path
of a hurricane you know there's no other
american city that has experienced such
tragedy
um and so we are a city of survivors we
have resilience
and even our ghosts even our ghosts have
resilience you know why would they leave
they leave for cbs this morning saturday
jamie wax new orleans
they they just rolled off the shelf
i don't know i don't know that looks
good i hope the ghost got to taste the
wine after this